pour le moment raymond qu'yat-il que
veux tu que tu m'a annoncé que je suis
sur ton héritage
doit pas traiter grand chose non juste
juste je veux revenir sur un seul et
même pas l'incident la dar k qui s'est
passé jeudi quand cancon a intervenu
génie kg voilà j'ai touché à tallinn
éditoriale c'est vrai il faut savoir une
chose c'est que il ya des équipes qui
bosse depuis 9 heures du matin sur une
ligne éditoriale avec des sujets et moi
pendant qu'ils bossent sur l'émission
moi je suis entre un livre et je fais
autre chose et je m'intéresse pas du
tout à l'émission j'arrive ici les 18
heures après le boulot et je vais
essayer comme une récré et quand je suis
pas d'accord avec toi 10 éditorial tu
sens qu'on attaque t équipe et tu me
dises n'était pas content tu peux y
aller pas effectivement je n'étais pas
content je suis parti en souhaitait pas
partir parce que j'étais
[Rires]
le gars et
j'ai pas pris et on était juste là haut
et tu m'as 10 km c'est qu'en plus sinon
l'objet je vous raconte tout c'est ça
l'art 4e avec senna car les vidéos lol
immobile
et je suis répond eh bien moi je me
sentirais pas dire à m j'ai pas vu je
captais plus
mais c'est vrai donc après ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end moi je mets un tweet
tu me réponds à mon tweet et après j'ai
vu des trucs faut que les gens alors
d'abord merci pour les messages les ans
vous vous êtes adorable mais quand vous
l'avez vous attaquez cyril en
l'occurrence attaqué mon pote ben weyts
a viré machin tu l'as pas défendu en
fait je suis le seul à avoir la chance
de me lever et partir comme ça et de
revenir c'est pas la provoc je suis
parti je suis parti une fois quand je me
suis embrouillé avec gilles je suis
parti une fois quand je me suis
embrouillé avec de leurs maux c'est la
troisième fois je suis le mec de tp qui
a quitté le plus de fois et plateau a
passé plus de temps à sortir qu'à rester
là et j'ai une chance pas possible
pendant deux mois je veux pas venir tu
peux tu me dire tu viens quand tu veux
tu es chez toi j'ai le sms tu viens tu
reviens quand tu veux c'est une chance
incroyable et c'est bien de se dire les
choses en direct on triche pas je sais
mais moi moi moi ce que j'aime c'est
révolu où vous dire la vérité ce qui me
fait le plus de peine et ce qui me
touche le plus chez raymond s'écoeurer
mou il est pénible pour moi et ça veut
dire qu'ils passent un mauvais week-end
et il ya des gens sur twitter qui dirait
que ça va alors qui sait pas que moi
richement pad
[Musique]
mes
frères gym suis même pas de coutume par
gimont bonus tech dentellières je le
vois très je pensais qu'il allait en
parler j'ai aujourd'hui suisse plus de
gens et en attaque et ça me fait alors
je suis at on voit de paddle ce week-end
j'ai à peine eu le doigt j'étais content
parce que les gens m'ont dit c'est bien
tu as bien fait machin mais en même
temps je suis pas content parce que j'ai
une chance pas possible on va pas se
mentir je fais ce que je veux et si
envoi c'est vrai tu bosses quasiment pas
l'émission donc voilà les gens c'est un
sachet dans ds qui du fait de jeu ben je
vous jure que c'est vrai quand vous
mettez des trucs négatifs sur moi et
c'est pas moi que vous faites de la
peine ça arrive mais c'est rigolo mais
c'était enfin ils sont tous pareils si
c'est drôle parce qu'on peut en parler
sont tous pareil ici wendy's ouais t'as
vu l'un et il nous beinheim est pareil
là il fait pareil bah oui ça me serait
j'aime pas s'il m'appelle j'y vais parce
que c'est ce qu'il faut que vous qu'au
peuple était spectateur comprenne c'est
qu'on est vraiment amis et qu'on est
vraiment une bande et que même quand on
se dit bah t'es un tocard ténu de machin
en fait on le pense sur le moment parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur l'âge mais
c'est comme une réunion de famille ou
pendant le pendant le gigot on entre à
se dire mais tu dis n'importe quoi mais
donc la moyenne a faim on s'embrasse on
dira dimanche prochain à la louche là
c'est la même chose
faire sans foi des émissions comme ça où
il me dit la vérité parce qu'on a taxé
équipe et moi je suis pas content avec
cette ligne éditoriale parce que je suis
pas venu là pour me faire menacer avec
une chaussure
je préfère qu'on se parle franchement
plutôt que les émissions montée ils sont
en direct moment on vous raconte des
conneries cette seule la cseries a
enregistré à les couper et la voyait
jamais et on est dans le monde des
bisounours pas couplées aux maple leafs
juste je voulais dire ça est en paix
maintenant